new details are emerging this morning
about the attacker in this week's deadly
rampage in London four people were
killed including a police officer and
more than four dozen people were injured
when Khalid Masood sped across
Westminster Bridge in a hired car and
plowed down pedestrians police shot and
killed Masood a Saudi embassy statement
says Masood taught English in a Saudi
Arabia under a work visa on at least two
occasions Jonathan Vigliotti is outside
Parliament with the latest Jonathan good
morning good morning it's been three
days since that attack and still no word
on a motive police believe Massoud was
acting alone
but they say it is entirely possible
that he had helped with the planning
Khalid Massoud seen here after
Wednesday's attack had a string of
previous assault and weapons charges
including possession of a knife in 2003
and was once investigated for violent
extremism but by 2017 at the age of 52
he'd fallen off the radar settling down
with his wife and three children on this
quiet street in Birmingham his neighbor
said he loved to garden did he ever show
any signs that he may have been
radicalized no I don't think so
he's look normal guy and his wife and
the doctors British police are now
trying to figure out what triggered his
deadly Parliament attack that killed
four people and injured dozens more
Massoud started life as Adrian wrestle a
Jaeho a british-born kid who went to
Christian school in Kent where he played
soccer it's believed he converted to
Islam during his several stints in jail
Richard Walton is London's former head
of counterterrorism it doesn't really
fit the normal profile of a young
terrorist inspired or directed by
Islamic state to al-qaeda you know an
older man of 52 years of age a father of
three children
Birmingham is home to the UK's largest
Muslim community and has become a
fertile recruiting ground for jihadis
over the past 20 years 39 people from
the city have been convicted of
terrorism related crimes Masood
neighbors say he abruptly packed up and
moved his family out three months ago
they say they hadn't heard from him or
seen of him until after this week's
attacks Alex Jonathan Vigliotti in
London thanks Jonathan